[Music]
in insect infestation is oh god no
insect though some invite it's your boy
Oh business
all right so imagine wacom all tucked in
like so like you go to this place it's a
stress reliever place right and then so
you get like a little hammer or
something like this and then you press a
button and then you could pick like
crickets or spiders or whatever and you
press a button and then they come up
like so and then you go worms and all
these ones are coming up there's a good
business that's mean what how do you how
do you profit off of it they pay for the
bugs yeah that take a smash I like you
people just start or what do you do with
the bugs after do you cook up a poodle
minish ache I'm gonna start a petition
uh to shut this business down who wants
to join me preemptive visit uh I want to
hear what he does after how did they do
it to righties
oh well I'm glad that you have we do
have a snake farm in the back they could
eat the snakes and I mean they could eat
the little bugs we also have what are
you smashing here there's a there's a
free food center for homeless people at
the very when they get smashed there's a
high source of protein yeah somebody
comes in and they could have snake food
and you're like oh no snakes on the back
man mm-hmm mm-hmm
nurses allegedly released cockroaches in
a hospital ward to get it shut down
they wanted to take a what is this in
America there cuz I feel like it fits
like in some Asian countries yeah it's
like oh you're never gonna guess which
country of Thailand let's remain in
Japan nope nope you're never in is it a
common country or is it you know cuz he
says boys are like Bolivia or some [ __ ]
Russia no Austria no you can Australia
hungry greener New Zealand nope Canada
Samoa darn to go no what do you think if
this video gets 5000 likes right now
then she'll tell us the answer wait I
know we're gonna - then I've been to
this country
Braco Turkey no Tunisia
no no France the [ __ ] you're getting
close no Spain
Croatia Oh closer monkeys Morocco no
dude where have you United Kingdom you
know what let's lots of blogs guest and
place that you went to I don't know no
no Massa don't Macedonia you're closer
with Croatia Bulgaria is that where you
went shroom farming no that is Croatia
cream oh look this video got 5,000 likes
oh no cuz when you say you'll never
guess that's all we started guessing the
weird ones oh I would enough thought of
Italy Italy for this kind of known for
scams is it the home of the mob I mean
that's not in Italy that know why is
Sicily it was here but taxes at home
there's a lot of their shipping
companies it's like the tree ads you
know they got they operate over there
you've never seen the Godfather it
started in the mother lion never side
yeah it's called La Cosa Nostra oh yeah
so this happened in Naples for pizza was
born and in the look horse-drawn Ostrom
is it probably's once have their own
area alright so this I'm gonna show you
this I know Italian culture i watch The
Godfather Oh were the pizza was invented
over did you know I never work let's do
did you know there's only real did you
know that there's only two kinds of
pizzas that are real and authentic I've
got the name from Naples and then
they're like kind of like this about it
yeah they have a pizza committee bro
yeah it's a and they're like there's
only two pizzas are real people s and
it's like some boring one know if you
eat Italian pizza though it's [ __ ] my
employee is it yeah I mean I love
Domino's Pizza Hut all that but that's a
different food not even people want to
eat that [ __ ] you ever talk about was
better than Ice Cube right tiful
I talked about actually lovemaking boots
or whatever but I love it I do but it
gives me heartburn
oh yeah [ __ ] me in all kinds of ways
but do you have to pay India to pay you
to paint play how come what does it does
it make Mexican people get heartburn or
is it just something I don't get it I
think it makes many people overweight
like it does everyone yeah well you're
gonna be in the middle of two Mexicans
that are not even close no do we look
I'm talking about eating that [ __ ]
constantly with that [ __ ] never you
barely eat at all what are you doing
constantly you like half a taco on your
home not anymore I've gained five pounds
only person that goes such a Paul in
orders the kids meal I do order any kids
meal I'm talking about the obesity rates
though down man it's pretty crazy just
like it is up here okay anyway we're
talking about how about roaches roaches
cockroaches yeah Italy so a patient film
video and put on social media and then
that's when the hospital director was
like oh no this is extraordinarily grave
and then so then that's when they found
out Jordan early grave that's the quote
they used I'm just reporting what I have
in front of me and so they were saying
that they believe that these bugs were
brought into the hospital in a bag
containing sawdust and a sheep because
you oh that's probably all they started
cockroaches off and then so there was
the in this person from the University
of Naples Department of Veterinary
Medicine told the local radio station
that these cockroaches were examples of
a certain type of species or like
cockroach species that come from
Argentina and Brazil so they for sure
we're not and they may be at the pet
store where you get those fancy
cockroach you bottom out of punchtrees
that's so stupid
that's us to be lucky they got a lot
and then they also realize that someone
dumped in there intentionally because a
lot of them were upside down like
disoriented really recent from wind
bring them to my shop they could be good
use
Oh in the bathroom no they're gonna be
tampered do they work together like ants
do or they're all I saw those it looked
pretty solo to me yeah I've never seen
them in group I don't know I can't
remember some giant swarm I usually see
one like I am song I've done nothing
what did they do eat things survive
forever apparently survive nuclear wars
yeah yeah but there's already other bugs
eating junk I just want to know what
they're for so these creatures are
normally used to feed reptiles I told
you for the snakes in the back yes so
they're saying that the nurses did this
in order to get the ward shut they're
trying to have a pizza party that's why
we never get pizza parties but no girl
and then this isn't the first time that
staff have been suspected of introducing
insects into hospitals in this city
because last year a patient's was filmed
covered and and an investigation found
open packets of sugar scattered around
staff lockers why they were trying to
find our attention morning yet more as
the motive for all this cuz they trying
to have a break what a funhouse ponder
Jesus they're always trying to get pizza
parties worse is a different Hospital
you want like a three-day weekend or
some [ __ ] any protesting you know well
they did save nurses and trade unionists
appeared to have sabotaged it don't get
no review transfer elsewhere they want
to be transfer someone no don't get sick
in Italy they'll cover you in short
trade unions that sounds like a union
group like trying to sound of talks like
see I told you the mob is alive and well
yeah alive and kicking I'm not a fan of
feeder anything why not it's sad it's at
home but it's true sir Peter is it like
that's not the ones that are being fed
part of nature they know sure oh they
need to eat yeah but but it's said
because they're usually behind that yeah
yeah cuz it doesn't really benefit the
animal that's doing it cuz then that
that means that they've been taken out
of their habitat you know and now they
have to rely on a human I just [ __ ] me
up yeah have you seen gars eat crickets
or a [ __ ] theater fish it's amazing
hmm yeah it looks like synchronized use
drama fish in there
well you you just yeah you could throw
their ovaries or whatever huh is there
water in them then they swim real quick
well gars are a type of fish and they're
like they look like they look like like
this schaeffler yeah and in doable and
in what school is like they'll swim in
kind of like a school so if you get a
couple of them together
don't be stink like that so if this one
moves they all move like this that's so
cool yeah when you throw in um like
goldfish or whatever they just start
shooting like arrows in the water and
then it's like it's crazy yeah and then
they just go they eat them in one bite
so that's it's not painful for the
goldfish kids just give them the flaky
things or whatever you have to give them
like no those are predatory fish so they
gotta eat something that's like made out
of are you like [ __ ] the same [ __ ]
dried up crickets or by Captain Crunch
yeah it provides stimulus for animals to
you right like yeah after they needle
and kill something is like they're like
mental stimulus or else they get a
really poor dick or if there's crickets
or something and they they jump forth
like that out of the water it's like
kind of like like like that like a lie
fishes cuz they do the crickets like
stand on the water's up yeah yeah they
float on the water
yeah so then they just pop like the croc
yeah I know I used to have a lot of pet
fish I like I like a good tank do you
have to have for that the fluid is in
there how bigger there is my tank was
about 200 gallons or something yeah
that's up there you imagine like this
couch right here for something like that
oh yeah or you know you you want
something huge because you want to add
you know so they have enough space to
swim around and dance and talk to their
friends and [ __ ] you know what a greater
degree Mike Tyson like bought a [ __ ]
tiger it's like the same kind of [ __ ]
yeah there's all kinds of when he was in
prison yeah with this mentality comes to
you right like where it's like I am rich
I need to have something that nobody
else yeah and that is like a predator or
knowledge [ __ ] oh oh the predator like
team like I control this yes I just like
watching nature yeah but you doing it on
a budget way which is nice yeah you can
get those fish and it's not that bad not
just got dog my tyson buying a [ __ ]
tiger yeah oh yeah that's cuz like once
you get to that level with like normal
things don't stimulating where it's
that's why you need to like up the ante
exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]